nos dicen divide los polinomios la forma
de tu respuesta debe de ser un polinomio
simple o un polinomio más una constante
entre x + 2 donde p de x es un polinomio
y acá es un entero bien esta es una
captura de pantalla de un ejercicio de
khan academy pero si estuviéramos
haciendo esto en khan academy tendríamos
que escribir la respuesta en la pantalla
pero aquí lo haremos a mano así que como
siempre pausa el vídeo e inténtalo por
tu cuenta antes de que lo trabajemos
juntos bien ahora vamos a trabajar
juntos x + 2 va a dividir a 3 x cúbica
más 4 x cuadrada menos 3 x + 7 como
siempre nos enfocaremos en los términos
de grado mayor cuántas veces cabe x en
3x kubica bueno cabe 3x cuadrada veces y
pondré ese resultado en la columna de
los términos de segundo grado
3x cuadrada por 2 y 6 x cuadrada 3x
cuadrada por x es 3x cúbica y aquí hay
algo muy meditado sobre la división
algebraica larga de cualquier manera
queremos restar lo que obtuvimos de lo
que tenemos acá arriba así que cambiaré
los signos estos términos se cancelan y
me queda 4x cuadrada menos 6 x cuadrada
lo que es menos 2x cuadrada y ahora
bajamos el menos 3 x y queremos pensar
en cuántas veces cabe x en menos 2 x
cuadrada bueno acabe menos 2 x veces así
que lo pondré en la columna de los
términos de primer grado menos 2x por 2
es menos 4 x menos 2x por x es menos 2 x
cuadrada y queremos restar lo que
tenemos en color naranja a lo que
tenemos en azul verdoso por lo que puedo
poner un paréntesis y multiplicar por un
signo negativo o bien distribuir el
signo negativo y cambiar de signo lo que
naranja estos dos se hacen positivos y
nos queda que los términos en x
cuadradas se cancelan y menos 3 x 4 x es
lo mismo que x bien bajamos el 7
cuántas veces cabe x en x bueno solo una
vez y lo pondré con un nuevo color en la
columna de los términos constantes 1 por
2 es 21 por x es x queremos restar estos
términos y nos quedaremos con 7 - 2 lo
cual es 5 y por lo tanto podemos
escribir esto como necesito un redoble
de tambor por aquí 3x cuadrada menos 2 x
+ 1 más
el residuo 5 entre x + 2 otra forma de
pensar este residuo es que tengo que
dimitir 5 entre x + 2 si quieres saber
exactamente el resultado de esta
división ahora bien si quiero que estas
dos expresiones sean completamente
idénticas tendré que poner la condición
n
x no puede ser igual a menos dos porque
si x es igual a menos dos estaríamos
dividiendo entre cero sin embargo para
el propósito de este ejercicio sólo
tienes que escribir en la pantalla esta
parte de aquí lo que no creo que sea la
cosa más sencilla de este mundo pero
vale la pena hacerlo bien nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo